let them see your true qualities my poor
judge it took over four hours each day
to fit gary oldman into the silicon face
molded foam bodysuit he needed to play
Winston Churchill the result is a
performance that is spectacular I'm
nearly sixty and I thought I'm not going
to gain 70 pounds I spent the rest of my
life actually losing weight so we always
knew that there would be some makeup
involved it was a bit give-and-take you
know we went a bit too far then we
pulled it back we found I think a nice
balance of me you still get a sense Gary
coming through the film follows
Churchill's first few weeks as prime
minister detailing the pressures he
faced from within his party to pursue
peace with Hitler at any cost
far from the popular figure we think of
today he's shown as a man with enemies
there were people who still remembered
him for some of the disasters in his
career I mean he the Gallipoli campaign
and which had been a fiasco in the First
World War had been church was brainchild
and he was known as the Blenheim Marat
as well from going from the Tories to
the liberal then back to the Tories
again and he was seen very much as
lacking in judgment and the royal family
in particular had a beef with him
because he'd supported King Edward the
eighth the King's brother during the
abdication crisis of 1936 and what if
your luck should run out some of the
world's finest actors have taken on
Churchill like Robert Hardy if
something's happened I know Albert
Finney no cake Michael Gambon it's a
bomb say bye-bye and recently brendan
gleeson thankfulness
escape of our army but will it be the
roll that gets Oldman his first Oscar
you're so busy stressing and worrying
about getting it right he making the
movie that you're not thinking about
that it's nice that they responded to
the work yeah for me a lot so will 2018
finally be Gary Oldman's year arguably
awards glory is long overdue
it's a Spencer Sky News